[Music]
was one of the first germans to contract
covet 19.
and he was one of the first to see that
symptoms can remain
even after the virus is gone five months
later
she was still experiencing difficulties
[Music]
i'm very tired i can easily go to bed
and fall asleep at eight o'clock
that wasn't the case before and that's
the main problem the tiredness
it's really debilitating some
ten to twenty percent of those infected
later suffer
from long covid recent studies suggest
women
are at greater risk than men
the lungs heart brain or mental health
can be affected
and it is still not exactly clear what
causes long covet
what can be done to treat it
hello and welcome to your covet 19
special i'm chris colbert berlin
being tired out of breath and feeling
like the infection simply won't leave
long coveted syndrome is grueling for
patients and a challenge
to medical professionals now researchers
in the german city of erlangen
might have taken an important step
towards understanding more about the
condition
a single drop of blood is all that's
needed for the examination
at the university of erlangen's max
planck institute in germany
scientists are looking for the causes of
long covet or post-covet 19 syndrome
in which patients suffer from lingering
breathlessness tightness in the chest
or fatigue
we've seen many different blood cells
react very strongly
they get bigger and have a greater
volume some become more malleable
others become more rigid these
characteristics might have something to
do
with the cells not passing through the
capillaries as easily
and instead getting stuck in the lungs
taken to measure the cell's malleability
scientists have developed a so-called
chip which contains
tiny holes finer than a human hair
blood is pumped through these canals and
filmed with a high-speed camera
the result healthy blood cells become
rod shaped infected ones remain round
clumps
this notation significantly alone the
finding that all blood cells change is
very significant
and what we then saw is that these
characteristics revert back to normal in
most patients
once they've got over the disease and
made a full recovery
the test method from erlangen provides
doctors with yet another tool for better
understanding covid19
and its long-term effects so there is
some indication
of what could be causing long-covered
symptoms but a lot still needs to be
figured out let's try to unpack of what
is known
so far with me is matthew bartles
professor
of physical medicine and rehabilitation
at montefiore medical center in new york
welcome back to our program
matthew as we just saw in the report
abnormalities in the blood
could be a cause of long covet
could this finding help in the
prevention or even therapy of it
uh this is a very interesting finding
because
you know we have not really to this
point understood the exact
causes of long covid and it is a
systemic
type of disease and it manifests in many
ways as you had in your intro piece
the idea that something that's a blood
abnormality may contribute to a systemic
diseases
is not at all uh something that would be
unusual
many people are familiar with sickle
cell and although that's a genetic
condition and very different
having abnormalities of the blood cells
there cause many effects including
central neurological symptoms
of fatigue cause musculoskeletal
complaints
problems with the joints so having
something that is present all throughout
the body like the blood showing these
long-term abnormalities
may be a very important step in
understanding part of where
we may be getting the causes of our long
covet
10 to 20 percent of covet patients end
up suffering from
long covert symptoms like fatigue
shortness of breath headache
how long do those usually last
well that's a very good point we don't
really know we are
you know at this point only a year and a
half into the pandemic but we are seeing
in our own
medical center and we have a long
covered clinic numerous patients that a
year out are still
seeing symptoms the fatigue seems to be
one of the greatest ones
there are of course patients who have
long-term lung damage that has come
from having had the covid and
that causes scarring that we don't know
if it's going to reverse but it seems in
very severe cases unfortunately
that it persists and we're now starting
to be concerned that that may actually
progress to the point where patients
may actually require lung
transplantation as the disease
progresses
uh and the neurologic symptoms the
many patients complain of a fogginess or
a little bit of mental clouding
that persists for a long time we
don't know exactly what the causes of
these things are but we do know that
exercise and that having patients
participate in our therapy programs the
rehabilitation things that we would do
for patients who have
other causes of either neurologic or
pulmonary or chronic fatigue or
musculoskeletal symptoms
do seem to have effect as well for this
population so
we're having benefit and we're actually
making them feel better
but we still have a problem with not
understanding fully the
long-term time course because it's just
too early for us to know the long-term
effects
okay we know that high age being
overweight
and other symptoms add to the risk of a
severe covet infection
do these conditions also contribute to
the risk of long covet
it appears that the folks who had higher
risk for having covets seem to have
more symptoms but it's not just only
those patients we have young
otherwise active and healthy patients
who are presenting
uh with long-covered symptoms and so
it's
a pretty broad spread but they do see
it does seem to be that the very severe
patients seem to have more of the
pulmonary and cardiac symptoms that
persist
whereas we're very surprised to see a
lot of patients who were never admitted
to hospital
and who were never in an intensive care
unit or on a breathing machine
who are presenting now with long covid
so they had a relatively
mild initial uh course but are still
presenting with
the fatigue and some of the mental
clouding and
that is very interesting and kind of
concerning because we don't necessarily
have a handle to say
oh you are definitely going to be free
of this because it happens to everyone
is the fact that we've just quote
unquote just
been one and a half years into this
pandemic does this
fact make it so difficult uh to do
proper research on long coving
well the uh the research there's some
things that are
are progressing rapidly and because
so many individuals have had long covet
this is a disease and have had covid
we're actually getting a much better
categorization of
uh for the long-term sequelae or the
long-term
side effects of this condition it's
difficult for us to actually tell
because we don't have the long term yet
so you know we don't know yet to say
what will happen to people 5
10 15 years from now but the other
challenge that we have is a lot of the
symptoms of long covid
overlap with symptoms that we can see
from other kinds of syndromes such as
chronic fatigue syndrome
or from mild dementias or from
other kinds of metabolic conditions that
may cause
some brain abnormalities which cause
people to have some confusion
and then as you resolve those underlying
metabolic conditions you can resolve
the underlying problem so we we really
at this point are looking at such a
constellation of so many symptoms
that it makes it a little hard to focus
in because it's not like long covert is
just causing one thing
it causes a whole constellation of
symptoms which may actually be either
enhanced or worsened by other conditions
or may
just be the other condition and we're
thinking it may be long covered
so it's a bit challenging for
researchers to actually tie it
get it tied up in a tight bundle because
we have so many complexities that are
actually in there
but the knowledge that we're getting now
is moving forward and for example the
blood study that you just mentioned
is one of these things where we're now
starting to see the physiologic
background
right matthew bartles professor of
physical medicine
and rehabilitation thank you for your
thoughts
thank you and from the feeling that
kovitt never left
it's now on to the worry of catching it
again
here's one of your questions for our
science correspondent derek williams
i had covid19 recently and recovered
then not long ago found out i was
exposed again
could i have been infected again
the data we have indicates that although
it's not impossible
it's it's highly unlikely a lot of
researchers have looked at this question
and come to that conclusion for instance
a recent large-scale study
involving over 25 000 health care
workers in britain
showed that having had covet 19 once
had a dramatic protective effect for at
least
seven months after an infection the
strength of the effect
was close to the one observed and people
who've had
two doses of our most effective vaccines
additionally the study showed that in
people who had coveted 19
then tested positive again for it a few
months or weeks
after convalescence the chances of
developing
symptoms were also much lower than in
those
who were infected for the first time but
if you had the disease and recovered it
still doesn't mean that you can just sit
back and relax
completely you still really need to
follow it up
with vaccination that's because although
recent studies into the robustness of
long-term immune response
in people who got the disease although
they've been very encouraging
we still don't know whether that
response
might wane over time in fact
a growing body of research now indicates
that
people who recovered and were
subsequently vaccinated
that they could very well have the best
protection of all
some experts believe the immune response
after that
double whammy will be so powerful
and so long lasting and those who've
recovered and been vaccinated
that they might never need future
booster shots
but for those of us who've only been
vaccinated
a lot of experts expect a booster shot
will be necessary
at some point down the line
[Music]
and that's all for this edition of covet
19 special for more information about
the pandemic you can
check out the covet 19 section on our
website at
dw.com for now thanks for watching
take care
[Music]
you